merci beaucoup
Anne merci à tous pour votre présence
pour vos chaleureux applaudissements et
merci d'être là et merci d'être vous
parce que nous vivons depuis six ans
d'incroyable chose ensemble nous vivons
une incroyable aventure au service des
Français et cette aventure elle va
continuer et effectivement Anne je suis
sûre que l'année qui s'ouvre l'année
parlementaire va être une grande année
au service de nos compatriotes
je voudrais pour commencer féliciter
notre nouveau président de groupe bravo
à toi Sylvain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis très heureuse que tu sois devenu
notre président de groupe parce que ça
fait plusieurs années que je te côtoie
que je travaille avec toi j'aime ta
façon de faire ta façon de dialoguer
j'aime l'écoute que tu as et la façon de
faire vivre notre groupe et ses
différentes sensibilités et je suis sûr
puisque tu seras un grand président de
groupe donc vraiment toutes mes
félicitations comme on parle de
président de groupe je ne peux pas
manquer de saluer notre présidente de
groupe qui vient de nous quitter et qui
elle aussi a été une grande présidente
de groupe ma chère Aurore merci d'être
là
[Applaudissements]
c'est une mission qui n'est pas facile
celle de président de groupe et tu l'as
assumé avec brio et je sais que tu
assumeras avec brio tes nouvelles
fonctions ministérielles mais en tout
cas merci de ton engagement moi j'ai
apprécié travailler avec toi n'avons pas
toujours été d'accord mais je suis sûr
que nous ne serons pas toujours d'accord
Sylvain et c'est ça la vie d'un groupe
c'est ça la vie d'un parti politique il
faut avoir des désaccords mais justement
ce qui fait un groupe c'est d'être en
capacité de les surmonter et de mettre
tout en oeuvre pour le faire et donc
vraiment très heureuse de travailler
d'avoir travaillé avec toi être
continuer sur les sujets qui sont
maintenant les tiens et de travailler
avec toi Sylvain je voudrais aussi
féliciter je sais pas si Pierre
Cazeneuve est dans les parages il est
encore là ou pas non est-ce qu'il y a
des rugbyman avec nous parce que je suis
allée à Toulouse pour le match d'envoi
de la Coupe du monde de rugby
parlementaire et ils sont arrivés
troisième figurez-vous donc bravo à eux
[Applaudissements]
cela étant dit nous avons vécu une année
passionnante une année difficile nous
avons remporté un certain nombre de
combats parlementaires et nous avons je
crois tenu nos engagements tenu nos
engagements au service des Français tenu
les engagements que le Président de la
République avait pris lors de la
campagne électorale je pense évidemment
à la réforme des retraites nous avons
été d'une solidarité sans faille pour
pouvoir franchir cette étape et tenir
cet engagement je pense aussi aux lois
relatives à l'environnement que ce soit
la loi portée sur les énergies
renouvelables sur le déploiement du
nucléaire et puis nous avons tenu nos
engagements sur le bloc régalien cher
Gérald avec la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur c'est le portée
par Sébastien sur la loi de
programmation militaire celle portée par
Eric la loi de programmation sur la
justice ce sont trois lois importantes
qui vont nous réarmer sur le plan
régalien que ce soit pour nos services
de police nos gendarmes nos magistrats
nos greffiers et puis bien sûr nos
militaires et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important et le budget qui
va nous être présenté sur lequel nous
allons travailler va justement traduire
très concrètement les engagements et les
votes que nous avons effectués durant
cette année
nous avons une année assez
exceptionnelle aussi sur le plan des
propositions de loi nous avons eu
finalement un phénomène totalement
inédit qui était qu'il y a beaucoup de
propositions de loi donc qui émane en
partie du groupe majoritaire qui ont été
adoptés 30 propositions de loi ont été
adoptées pendant une année de façon
définitive et 18 l'ont été et sont
encore en navette donc cela fait près
d'une cinquantaine de propositions de
loi qui ont été adoptées au moins en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
et ça je crois que c'est le résultat de
la fameuse nouvelle méthode nouvelle
méthode que je prenais au mois de
juillet 2022 dès mon accession à la
présidence de l'Assemblée nationale et
nouvelle méthode qu'Elisabeth que je
voudrais vraiment saluer
[Musique]
à ce moment-là de mon intervention parce
que cette nouvelle méthode elle vit
grâce à toi grâce à l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement qui sont à notre
écoute à l'écoute du Parlement que ce
soit à l'Assemblée nationale ou au Sénat
et je pense que grâce à cela nous avons
pu remplir un certain nombre
d'engagements et nous avons plus pu
avancer dans l'intérêt des Français donc
merci à toi Elisabeth et
et merci à 30 bien sûr
et j'en profite pour remercier François
qui mène notre groupe de sénateurs avec
brio il est en campagne électorale alors
pas pour lui mais pour un certain nombre
de nos collègues et nous sommes tous et
je vous invite à être tous derrière nos
sénateurs qui sont en renouvellement la
bataille est difficile mais nous devons
la gagner nous le devons à François qui
est un formidable chef de groupe au
Sénat
[Applaudissements]
alors tous notre institution fonctionne
parce que vous êtes un groupe formidable
parce que nous avons adopté une nouvelle
méthode parce que nous avons réussi à
trouver les bons équilibres à
l'Assemblée nationale et je voudrais
vous dire un mot sur le fonctionnement
interne de l'Assemblée nationale on
parle par en ce moment du renouvellement
des instances de l'Assemblée donc le
bureau notamment avec séquesters sévices
présidents et ses secrétaires et je
voudrais vous dire que le bureau que
nous avons actuellement est un bon
bureau il est c'est un bon bureau pour
plusieurs raisons c'est un bon bureau
parce qu'il respecte notre règlement
vous me direz c'est un minimum être
notre règlement prévoit que le bureau
doit représenter les différentes
sensibilités politiques qui sont
présentes à l'Assemblée nationale et
c'est le cas aujourd'hui du bureau qui
représente l'intégralité des équilibres
politiques
notre bureau doit être paritaire je vous
indique que j'ai fait les comptes tout à
l'heure nous sommes 12 femmes sur 22
membres donc il est largement paritaire
et donc moi je crois que le bureau donc
il correspond à nos règles et surtout il
nous a permis de fonctionner le bureau
depuis deux ans a adopté à l'unanimité
le budget de l'Assemblée nationale il a
adopté à chaque fois les propositions
que nous lui faisions en ce qu'il
fallait sanctionner certains
parlementaires en ce qu'il fallait avoir
un certain nombre d'orientation sur la
vie de l'institution tel que le projet
de nouvelles accueil du public et donc
ce bureau et je le crois un bon bureau
et donc la position qui est la mienne le
souhait qui est le mien après et
évidemment une discussion approfondie
avec Sylvain en tant que président de
groupe majoritaire mais également avec
Marc Laurent Marc Angelli et Jean-Paul
Mattei c'est de prôner le statu quo et
de travailler pour que le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale puisse continuer
cette deuxième années de notre mandat de
la même façon qu'il l'a effectué pendant
la première année donc je travaille en
ce moment à cela je rencontre l'ensemble
des présidents de groupes politiques
mais c'est la position que je soutiens
bien sûr en dialogue constant également
j'ai parlé des présidents de groupe mais
en dialogue constant également avec
Franck avec la première ministre et avec
le président de la République c'est
important parce que si l'on a pu voter
autant de textes si on a pu remplir
autant d'engagements pris par le
Président de la République et notre
majorité lors des élections législatives
nous avons pu le faire parce que nous
avons une institution qui fonctionne qui
tourne qui n'a jamais été bloqué et la
composition du bureau a permis ce
fonctionnement et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense en conscience
qu'il est très important de reconduire
ce bureau tel qu'il est aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir permettre à notre institution de
continuer à remplir pleinement sa
mission pour l'année qui s'ouvre
pour terminer je voudrais vous dire que
je vais continuer évidemment la
politique d'ouverture que j'ai menée à
l'Assemblée nationale ouverture vers les
citoyens toujours plus de créneaux de
visite pour que vous puissiez permettre
aux habitants de vos circonscriptions de
venir visiter l'Assemblée nationale plus
d'expositions plus d'assemblées des
idées plus de rencontres citoyennes
parce que je pense vraiment que cette
Assemblée nationale doit s'ouvrir au
peuple pour redevenir pleinement la
Maison du Peuple donc nous continuerons
cette politique et vous verrez dans la
cour d'honneur il y a une magnifique
oeuvre de Pierre Fabre qui vient d'être
installée et qui est constitué de 577
fils de couleurs bleu blanc rouge
représentant la représentation nationale
j'espère qu'elle vous plaira nous allons
continuer bien sûr à travailler sur avec
les groupes pour accentuer nos points de
convergence lors des semaines
transpartisanes les semaines que nous
avions
initié que nous allons je l'espère faire
grandir parce que c'est je crois de
notre responsabilité de continuer à
rassembler de rassembler autour de nos
valeurs et de notre projet vous pouvez
pour cela compter évidemment sur mon
engagement total et n'hésitez pas et je
passe ma petite annonce n'hésitez pas si
vous souhaitez que l'on fasse un
déplacement que l'on organise un
déplacement dans une de vos
circonscriptions j'ai déjà réalisé 27
déplacements sur tout le territoire
hexagonal et ultramarins j'ai été chez à
peu près 40 parlementaires je pense que
c'est toujours aussi important que nous
allions ensemble à la rencontre de nos
concitoyens sur tous les territoires
quel qu'il soit donc n'hésitez pas si
vous avez des souhaits des entreprises
des associations des points vraiment
d'intérêt sur vos territoires des jeunes
ou des assemblées à rencontrer je suis
toujours très heureuse de pouvoir me
déplacer et changer rencontrer nos
concitoyens parce que c'est pour eux que
nous œuvrons pour faire en sorte de
bâtir la France de demain pour eux et
avec eux je vous remercie